et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
karima delli bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est députée
européenne vous préciser la commission
transports au parlement européen vous
êtes surtout en ce moment la candidate
de la gauche aux régionales dans les
hauts de france et des écologistes la
gauche et des écologistes
nous vous nous direz tout ça ensemble
pendant 20 minutes on a longuement parlé
des régionales évidemment on est en soi
pendant 20 minutes pony interview au
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et c'était bonjour ses fans bonjour aux
regards des fans qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on va parler des régionales je vous le
disais mais d'abord l'actualité karima
delli et c'est plusieurs plages de corse
on en parlait plusieurs plages de corse
fermé et après une pollution aux
hydrocarbures soulier pollution aux
hydrocarbures probablement causée par un
dégazage sauvage
alors il ya des sanctions qui existent
elles ont été renforcées ces sanctions
visiblement c'est pas dissuasif
est-ce qu'il faut encore les renforcer
et comment on renforce les contrôles
également de ce navire vous savez on est
dans une situation extraordinaire
la protection de la nature on n'a jamais
mis autant moins de moyens qu auparavant
je le dis parce que par exemple sur les
migrants quand je vois le programme
frontex au niveau européen on se met des
moyens et la protection de la nature de
mériterait qu'on mette de réels moyens
parce que ce genre notamment d' incident
risque dans l'avenir si on donne pas des
sanctions exemplaires de recommencer
parce que là pour l'instant on est en
train de chercher notamment l'auteur de
ce drame parce qu'il faut parler de
drames et ensuite il faudra aussi
regarder dans la législation
quand je vois que la france traîne des
pieds pour juste inscrire l'écocide dans
notre loi est de dire après il faudra
attendre l'europe il faudra attendre
marly la région en mai les instances
internationales on a la capacité de
montrer l'exemple et à partir du
justement de ceux d'un monde devrait se
dire monteront à quel point la capacité
d'une loi peut avoir un impact et à
partir de l'application
tu es au niveau européen et des dires
nous l'avons fait maintenant nous le
réclamons haut niveau et sur le papier
les sanctions elles sont fortes quand
même hein on parle de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement en parle de 15 millions
d'euros d'amendé
sur le papier mais visiblement ça
n'empêche pas ce genre de drame comme
vous dites comment on fait pour éviter
ça
vous savez moi je suis la rapporteure
notamment du secteur maritime à l'europe
ça fait des années que je dis que tous
les systèmes maritimes doivent être
remis à plat voyez on ad et corridors
sur lequel les bateaux pourraient passer
on pourrait les tracés on pourrait les
suivre par exemple c'est pas le cas on y
suit est un gros bateau comme ça qui dès
qu'ils dégagent dans des quantités
pareil on n'est pas capable de retrouver
leur doit de retrouver sa route de
l'identifier ils sont pas tous tracés
ces bateaux-là en méditerranée à l'heure
actuelle non et c'est ça le drame parce
que tout le monde ne joue pas le jeu
c'est ça le problème
hier qu'ils ne jouent pas le jeu par
exemple la foule lui roth devrait jouer
notamment le rôle d'arbitré vous voyez
aujourd'hui on est encore en train de le
chercher
donc là il ya un problème et ensuite il
va falloir anticiper et c'est là où
c'est le drame
c'est ce secteur maritime va devoir
rentrer dans la transition
demain il va falloir sortir des fuels
lourds demain on devra avoir un mix
énergétique dans les bateaux demain il
va falloir faire en sorte que on parle
des ports hacker zéro émission tout ça
on a pris énormément de retard mais
encore faut-il avoir une volonté
politique alors nous on l'a dans les
textes le parlement européen mais en
face de nous ça se lit pas mais qui n'a
pas cette volonté politique ce sont les
chefs d'état vous savez l'europe s'est
passé comme une copropriété 1
si vous voulez faire des travaux fin
attente de l'accord à l'unanimité donc
là il ya un problème aussi de fonds vous
voyez et je crois que c'est là où ça
devient très dramatique c'est que on
saisit jamais les bonnes occasions
ronan dantec parler de l'amour fait
disent tout à l'heure il parlait des
événements qui s'était passé notamment
en bretagne personnes à tirer leçon on a
une loi royal qui était là inquiète on a
fait le travail en ont dit on est là on
a là une cession la plus sévère
notamment en europe et alors
et alors vous voyez rien n'est fait et
c'est là le drame
moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui au
niveau des mers il faudra des traces et
c'est à dire on a des dt route un don un
corridor imposé pendant des corridors là
on parle beaucoup des autoroutes de la
mer etc
voyez tout ça il va falloir le tracé
ensuite il va falloir vraiment cette
industrie va falloir la reconvertir et
assez vite parce que ce genre de
problème là on parle juste de la saison
touristique
parce qu'on se dit oh là là ça y est
c'est l'été mais ce sera des
conséquences sur plusieurs années au
fait c'est ça le drame
on va continuer à parler évidemment
climat environnement puisque le sénat a
entamé hier l'examen de la loi climat
est entrée de jeu le sénat a voté à
l'unanimité un nouvel article impose à
la france de respecter ses engagements
européens en matière de baisses
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
avez été agréablement surprise de ce
vote du sénat c'était important c'est un
bon signal pour vous mais c'est un beau
signe elle mais c'est pas méchant de
dire ça est-ce qu'on respecte les
accords de paris en france non on avait
une opportunité en or et je vous le dis
en or tout le monde et je peux le dire
je suis députée européenne
tout le monde nous a regardés sur la
convention c'est sur la convention
climat et tout le monde a dit mais c'est
quoi cette nouvelle manière de faire
avec les citoyens tout le monde était
enchanté au niveau européen au point que
désormais on parle au niveau européen
des conventions citoyenne sur l'europe
parce qu'ils veulent mais justement sont
inspirés pour faire du débat européen
ce genre de consultation mais qu'elle
rate emmanuel macron a raté son rendez
vous avec l'écologie et pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui skie qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché dans un formule parce qu'elle a
été appliqué nos deux pays sur d'otay
mesa très bien marché mais parce que là
le problème de fond et je vous le dis
c'est qu'on peut pas dire promis juré
craché
vous la convention climat sans filtre
j'appliquerai vos propositions et du
jour au lendemain on trahit les
propositions vous voyez est ce qui s qui
a pas aussi le fait que le thème était
beaucoup trop large ou pas assez bien
cadrer le fait qu'à l'arrivée on
la convention accouche entre guillemets
250 propositions de mémoire c'est génial
mais non c'est pas beaucoup c'est une
opportunité
et c'est là où on est en retard tout le
monde regarde joe biden en disant m tout
le monde i am avocat et ce bac sailly
sont de retour notamment dans les
accords de paris mais sait on va
peut-être parlé tout à l'heure mais
c'est quand même extraordinaire
joe biden a compris que la transition
écologique c'est une transition beau
pour climat pôle emploi bon pour le
climat bon pour l'emploi
vous voyez et nous on est en train
d'accoucher de mesures est comme ça
alors qu'on ait été les premiers à faire
le grenelle de l'environnement s'était
pas il ya un siècle
c'était en 2007 vous voyez et on est en
2021 et on est toujours en train de se
dire alors est-ce qu'on va réellement
mettre des propositions qui vont être un
petit peu dans le sens de la transition
écologique mais où est ce que tu sais
rien fait comme les américains c'est à
dire que le plan de relance en europe il
est quand même il est quand même très
lié à la à la conversion à la con à la
transition écologique pardon merci s'il
ya quand même il ya quand même des
moyens il comme une grosse partie de ce
clan qui est censé être dédiés à la
transition écologique on ne rentrera sur
la même la même logique c'est bon pour
le climat c'est bon pour l'emploi
moi j'aimerais bien vous croire mais au
fait des choses aussi simples
franchement quand on dit l'obligation de
rénovation thermique
ça c'est un lien en plus c'est bon pour
l'emploi parce que dans l'un dans la
rénovation s'est éteint en seconde fois
directe vous n'allez pas le délocaliser
votre maison à l'autre bout de la terre
je suis désolé voilà c'est de l'emploi
direccte locale mais même cette
obligation la trouve pas dans la loi
vous voyez ça n'existe plus moi j'étais
hyper contente en 2007
hoog lorsque la france dit marron sur
des néonicotinoïdes et là tout le monde
nous regarde pas ce que les autres pays
qu'est ce qu'ils disent ils sont les
premiers on va faire la même chose
ben non on les remet et donc on a l'air
ridicule parce que tout le monde y au
fait en 2016 ils les ont retirées et
maintenant elles remettent et donc même
au niveau du débat européen
les gens nous
garde nous que le voisin ils nous disent
mais à quoi vous vous dites vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui en matière d'écologie la
france elle est ridicule elle n'est pas
à la hauteur des enjeux
et c'est là où je dis beaucoup de blabla
mais peu de résultats se retrouver à la
traîne des autres pays pour vous ah bah
moi je pense que sérieusement si le l6
la france et c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
petit décalage parce que monsieur mâcon
il est de notre génération en tout cas
de la mienne il devrait comprendre que
c'est maintenant ou jamais il devrait
comprendre que justement les combats et
franchement les propositions de la
convention citoyenne s'est pas
révolutionnaire non plus envoyé c'est
pas méchant de vous dire ça mais de
s'appuyer sur ça et de dire ça y est on
démarre une nouvelle ère la france va
être dans les meilleurs élèves de la
classe au niveau européen on n'est pas
capable de le faire
voyez je pense qu'on a malheureusement
je pense que c'est très dommage parce
que je pense que ce sont les générations
futures qui vont jugé très sévèrement ce
gouvernement est que les générations
futures
on ne doit pas on ne va pas à leur voler
comme ça leur destin trouve ça assez
égoïste est assez injuste voilà un
dernier mot là-dessus karim lips faut
emmener le temps par les votes de votre
programme régional les sénateurs ils ont
supprimé le délit d' écocide tel que
prévu initialement par le gouvernement
alors même les sénateurs écologistes
s'en félicite un disant que c'était une
forme d'hypocrisie
est-ce que vous allez porter ce sujet au
niveau européen mais on le porte déjà
yannick jadot qui porte ce sujet là on
le porte tous mais c'est encore été
battu à coire de l'inscrire dans la loi
et donc là aussi c'est une fois que
l'europe l'un rares inscrit dans sa
législation
elle pourra arriver au niveau
international et est-ce que ça soit nous
on l'a fait maintenant on joue dans la
cousine gouailleuse que cela soit
inscrit dans le schéma actuel à nous
vous savez nous les écologistes on n'a
pas le temps de parler on agit le temps
est à l'action face aux dérèglements
climatiques
on le voit t-il tous les jours il reste
que quelques années pour agir donc on
agit allez on va parler des régionales
stéphane aubin en danger tout de suite
serait votre première mesure si vous
étiez élu la tête de la région alors
présidente de la région deux frangins
style prévu entre qu'est ce que vous
faites alors président de la région des
rois de france
j'installe tout de suite une convention
citoyenne pour le climat tout de suite
et ensuite je sûr que le point
particulier en général ou belote plus
ciblées n'ont en général et la deuxième
mesure et je le dis de manière assez
simple
j'aiderai toutes les associations
environnementales dont qui ont été vidés
on va supprimer leurs subventions
ce que vous savez on a un xavier
bertrand qui a pas du tout la main verte
1 mais il a eu la main très lourde
notamment pour couper les subventions
aux associations environnementales et
pourquoi at il fait ça parce que
justement l'heure nous nous sommes la
dernière région de la transition
écologique
voyez la dernière sur quels critères
vous pas surtout sur la pollution de
l'air
on est les champions du monde sur la
question de l'agriculture bio on est les
champions du monde - 2 % de bio voyez on
est dans une région qui était fragilisée
par la pauvreté par le chômage et qu'est
ce qu'on fait en fait rien alors que
qu'à six ans en grande pompe au pain on
avait rift qui n'ont disait la région de
la troisième révolution industrielle
ce qui nous fait plaisir parce qu'on se
disait cool on va rentrer dans la
transition
rien n'a été fait on avait lancé c'était
la gauche et les écologistes
un grand plan de 100 mille logements de
rénovation aussi au bout de six ans
ces 5000 logements rénovés mais de qui
se moque t'on voyez et donc est ce qu'on
a fait ça c'est le résultat de monsieur
bertrand qui a donné notamment le
portefeuille de l'environnement à
chasseurs
c'est ce qu'on appelle du clientélisme
pathétique et moi je crois que ces gens
là sont encore dans le déni climatique
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
absolument que la gauche et les
écologistes
wigan cette région parce que nous sommes
trop de retard sur l'environnement en
france y'a quand même un sujet autour
des éoliennes par exemple via les
endroits où il y en a trop on peut se le
dire
jallet il ya quand même un gros impact
sur le paysage et puis il ya eu un
développement qu'il peut dans certains
secteurs s'est fait de manière un peu
anarchique vous le dites moi comme si
j'étais la prius et la région des hautes
france non mais mais qu'est ce qu'il a
fait pendant si c'est ce que vous est-ce
que vous avez vous êtes élu vous
poursuivrez le débat viennent d'abord le
constat c'est bien beau de crier fallait
faire ils disent c'est l'anarchie sur
notre territoire mais ils ont fait quoi
ces gens là or on a aujourd'hui marine
le pen qui porte le même programme que
xavier bertrand ils sont pour le
nucléaire contre l'éolien pour la chasse
à courre je vais pas faire toute la
liste parce que ce serait beaucoup
voyaient là sur les éoliennes mais c'est
assez simple il ya les accords de paris
on n'a pas le choix la loi de 2015 c'est
la loi de madame royal qui dit on doit
accélérer les énergies renouvelables
donc c'est la loi qui nous le dit je
suis désolé moi je respecte la loi
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on fait bien sûr il
faut accélérer dans les énergies
renouvelables éolien mais pas seulement
il ya le soleil est là mais je me
souvienne qu'est ce que vous faites pas
ce que vous sentez qu'il ya quand même
une colère d'une partie de la population
sont les retravailler une finale c'est
un sujet je dis juste qu'il faut
travailler avec les acteurs les élus les
citoyens etc et de montrer aussi à quel
point c'est gagnant gagnant
c'est la filière et je le répète qui est
en croissance de 25% par an dites moi
une filière qui augmente des 25000
faisant partie président que vous
implanter de nouvelles éoliennes encore
dans la région de tours à sa résidence
je ne travaille pas comme vous avez père
tranquille a fait n'importe quoi je
laisse en place je mets en place une
gouvernance jeu rétabli l'équilibré des
territoires
je travaille d'abord avec les élus et
les citoyens et on aura des
consultations publiques voyait même si
aujourd'hui la ressent forcément de
nouvelles éoliennes
abbas il y en aura forcément des
nouvelles mais en tout cas il y aura une
consultation il faut arrêter aussi de
dire on met plein d'éoliennes par une
éolienne pour pouvoir la mettre en place
il faut un débat public il faut une
enquête publique et c'est très suivi en
ansa on dit pas on va faire des
éoliennes comme ça moi ce que je
regrette le plus c'est que oui on a
beaucoup d'éoliennes mais ça crée de
l'emploi
c'est ça qu'il faut dire et le pire de
tout ça c'est qu'on avait le plus
merveilleux centre de formation le wind
lab en picardie qu'est ce qu'on a fait
ça on l'a supprimée alors que 80% des
jeunes rentrés dans ce wind lave de
formation 80% sortent avec un cdi vous
connaissez beaucoup de secteurs vous où
on sort avec un cdi et ensuite on nous
dit mais à la place on la met de le p r
mais regardez ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment dans le sud de la
chine où même le edf est obligée
d'appeler des experts américains sur le
père parce qu'ils ne savent pas
contrôler il risque d'avoir une fuite
nan mais est moins ma responsabilité en
tant que président c'est la sécurité des
gens vous voyez bas puisque vous parlez
de sécurité bon alors c'est pas une
compétence c'est pas une compétence
directe des régions la sécurité mais ça
reste un sujet un sujet de préoccupation
important noeud au niveau national
particulièrement en ce moment
est ce que vous auriez vous auriez des
propositions d des innovations
particulière dans ce domaine dans la
limite de ce que peut faire un président
de région
ah bah oui alors tout d'abord je me suis
retenu et monsieur bertrand qui était
dans le même parti politique qui crie
beaucoup sur la sécurité comme ça et qui
n'ont rien fait il appartenait à l'ump
sous nicolas sarkozy c'est eux qui ont
supprimé dix mille emplois de police de
proximité vous le dit très bien il faut
le redire la sécurité c'est une
compétence directe d'accord mais moi
président il ya trois choses sur lequel
je dois insister tu d'abord moi je suis
expert sur les transports vous savez
quand moi je prends le train en tant que
femme on peut avoir des transports ça
c'est une coupe et on sera là donc on
remet à plat la convention entre la sncf
et la région des hauts de france et on
dit on de plus de police ferroviaire
dans les traces ça c'est possible c'est
ce que je ferai la deuxième chose et moi
je suis assez flipper compte que ces
messieurs n'en parle jamais mais celle
et les féminicides dans ma région il ya
146 femmes qui sont décédées à cause
notamment
de leur ont 20 ou est-ce que ex conjoint
il faut qu'on ait ce rôle de protéger
les femmes et leurs enfants parfois donc
je créerai notamment des maisons de
protection pour l'ensemble de l'islam ce
mini-site c1 c'est un chiffre énorme
sait sur quelle période là bas là c'est
juste une bulle mais voilà vous voyez
qu'on sait g et ben voilà est donc tout
le monde fait de la mousse un peu sur la
sécurité
moi je veux de la sécurité pour les
femmes dans les trains mais je vais
aussi de la sécurité alimentaire
comment ça se fait que notre région est
une région quasiment à grande majorité
sur les pesticides et je veux que mes
premiers jeux fusion de la sécurité à
proprement parler est ce que par exemple
vous président de vous développer la
vidéoprotection
mais une caméra vous avez une agression
est ce qu'une caméra vous protègent non
il faut mettre du personnel et je vais
vous donner un exemple très concret dans
une ville que je connais bien qui
s'appelle roubaix bassin de vie cent
mille habitants
voyez cent mille c'est beaucoup on a
enlevé tout le personnel dans la gare on
a juste mis notamment des guichets
automatiques est ce que c'est ça ben à
nous donc de loin de l'humain et jaguar
tellement de grève non bien sûr c'est ça
combien vous pouvez vous avez chiffré ça
parce qu'on a on recevait audrey pulvar
la semaine dernière sur ce vieux truc
qui me disait qu'elle voulait carrément
mettre un agent de sécurité par rame
dans l'est dans les rer notamment le
soir et c'est ce que ce qui peut ce qui
nécessite beaucoup d'embauchés est ce
que vous êtes sur un petit volume ou ou
quelque chose de considérable d'abord il
faut regarder les bassins de vie donc ça
ça ce sont des négociations qui seront
avec les élus locaux on faut arrêter la
médaille de teint le droit d'entrer dans
la dentelle et ensuite moi je ne suis
pas une chef de clan je suis là chef
d'une équipe on travaille ensemble et
donc c'est la nouvelle méthode au sein
des hauts de france va être la
présidente qui travaille comme au niveau
européen avec tous les acteurs autour de
la table on décide pas seul et on fait
pas de là de la mousse sans savon comme
j'ai là comme le fait monsieur xavier
bertrand justement puisque vous parlez
des clips vous avez réussi l'union de la
gauche et des écologistes vous êtes à la
tête d'une liste qui rassemble europe
ecologie les verts le parti socialiste
le parti communiste et la france
insoumise c'est inédit pour ces
régionales génération est ce le partira
c'est parti j'ai nommé juste dans les
sondages vont plafonner pour le moment
autour de 20% selon les sondages est ce
que pour vous c'est un échec alors d'une
part c'est pas un échec
d'autre part c'est qu'on a parlé très
tardivement de cette élection régionale
et ce qui est un scandale absolu en
termes de démocratie on a nationalisé
notamment ce scrutin ensuite de ça on a
confondu les élections lorsque monsieur
xavier bertrand parle on sait pas s'il
est prêt le candidat à la présidentielle
où le candidat aux régionales
pareil où on a instrumentalisé on voit
bien que monsieur sune lui c'est un peu
le porte parole de marine le pen et on a
une suite on a vu l'arrivée de cinq
ministres pour vous c'est ça qu'il
excluait dos derrière il ya quoi l'idée
de directement pensé cela implique votre
corps ou celle des lacs a également de
la faiblesse de la marche et du dedans
se plaît lisez
non là moi je crois que la faiblesse de
de ce score se faire attention aux
sondages à des soins je vous me
connaissez un mois je sais j'ai toujours
su faire mentir les sondages
et moi je crois que surtout c'est que
les gens ne connaissent pas ces
élections mais là on est à cinq jours
jusqu'au temps qu'un ben oui messieurs
les frères moi j'ai alors sur le plateau
de public c'est d'un je le dis très
tranquillement j'appelle l'ensemble des
habitants des hauts de france notamment
à se dire que tous nos indicateurs sont
au rouge
maintenant c'est terminé il va falloir
les mettre au vert et d'aucuns qu'une
alternative à l'extrême droite est à
cette droite extrême incarné par xavier
bertrand
il y à l'alternative d'un projet
enthousiasmant porteur d'espoir mais
aussi de solutions concrètes
il faut arrêter les fausses promesses
vous voyez moi j'ai j'ai regardé on a
trahi pense plus de six mois sur un
programme concret keshi frais et qui
montre justement qu'aujourd'hui on veut
changer la région donc il faut se
mobiliser se mobiliser et se glisser
tout genre vous n'arrivez pas à faire
mentir les sondages
dimanche soir est ce que vous pouvez
affirmer avec certitude que vous ne vous
retirer pas quel que soit votre score et
quel que soit le score de sébastien
chenu alors je ne suis pas madame irma
je ne lis pas dans les boules de cristal
encore donc vous non je ne sais pas ce
qui va se passer dimanche
je ne sais pas quel sera le taux de
participation je ne sais pas tout ça
vous voyez la véritable question c'est
moi je fais campagne jusque vendredi
soir cela veut dire qu'ils arrêtent pas
fermé à l'idée d'un retrait si le
rassemblement national et très vite je
mange pas la peine de poser la question
alain bichsel pour vaud est laissée à la
belle mais ils ont peut-être envie de
savoir ce que va devenir leur bulletin
bah la chaîne de poser la question par
rapport à 7 ce barrage notamment
l'extrême droite
je sais quand même responsable nous
l'avons fait en 2015
l'histoire ne peut pas se répéter
aujourd'hui vous voyez vous êtes vous
êtes très bien fois qu'il arrive vous me
servez votre liste je le dis très
clairement
15 je ferai tout pour gagner cette
élection parce que les habitants et de
france arrachent rassemblements
nationaux mais ne me dites pas de faire
barrage au front national aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il ya besoin de faire barrage
où moi je connais pas les résultats du
dimanche soir vous voyez moi mon but là
dans les cinq jours qui avait gagné les
avez raison sauf que mercy mais vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous pouviez
faire mentir les sondages mais sébastien
chenu il peut aussi faire mentir les
sondages
et en plus quand même se retrouver
dimanche soir dans une situation où le
rassemblement national même si ça paraît
peu probable soit en situation de gagner
cette région il faudra bien prendre une
décision par rapport à ça aujourd'hui
vous est-ce que ça fait partie des
choses dont vous discuté ensemble ce qui
est ligne claire et est ce que cette
perspective là ne fait pas partie des
choses qui vous affole ma perspective
est clair faire campagne jusqu'à
vendredi soir minuit aller chercher la
victoire faire démentir c'est sondages
voilà et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci karima dernier vous merci beaucoup
d'invités ce matin pour des questions
d'équité on va regarder ensemble la
liste de vos adversaires dans cette
région des hautes france est listes sont
en lice pour ce scrutin qui a donc le
dimanche et on le rappelle tous les
jours à nos téléspectateurs l'élection
c'est dimanche on regarde à une de ouest
france stéphane c'est un tout autre
sujet c'est l'immobilier à la une de
ouest france les prix flambent la
pénurie d'offre s'accentue merci
stéphane merci beaucoup karim wade merci
à vous très bonne journée
[Musique]